sechs kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute spielen wir
trump auf diesem server hier der heißt
bergwerk labs die ip kenne ich nicht
befürchten auf jeden fall spielen
teilnahm und leute es gibt eine menge
menge menge zu erzielende menge ist
passiert in bester zeit wo fange an
klassiker wie fangen bei der sache an
die vorerst an gefallen ist und zwar
habe ich letztens ein video hochgeladen
das hieß tropez gold apfel versteckt
erstmal dazu haben sie beschrieben sowie
der gehalt bist du bescheuert man das
ist kein op gold apfel das ist normaler
gold apfel und da ist mir aufgefallen
dass ich den titel miss verständlich
geschrieben habe es ging ja nicht darum
dass sap gold äpfel sind
das ist quasi den op gold ab und
versteckte es versteckt und wenig die
äpfel und magazine müsstest das jetzt
sage aber einfach nur um das ding
klarzustellen für euch hoch ist aber
eigentlich ging in dem video habe ich
mich mit einer anderen spielerin die
auch rechte jump league spielt sich da
gut auskennt und halten sie gut kannte
was mehr zeigen wollte getroffen nämlich
sellin und wir sind dann zusammen
runtergegangen haben das jump'n'run
jeder rallye für sich gemacht so lief
alles ganz gut würde ich sagen
dann sind als das match gekommen hier
pakets gemacht haben uns getroffen und
dann hat sie mir dass sie gut gezeigt
wie er mich darüber aufgeregt dass das
zieht so unfassbar ändern ist und wie
irgendjemand das finden kann weil es war
wirklich so rennen versteckt hier ist
nur ein kleiner ausschnitt wie das also
man muss konnte klavier findet denn
sowas ja übrigens wenn ich daran denke
habe ich das video jetzt hier auch
irgendwo verlinkt also irgendwo hier ist
es eventuell verlinkt aber wenn du
eigentlich realistisch sind leute dann
vergesse ich so was immer es ist so
schlimm wie oft habe ich schon gesagt
vielleicht irgendwann erfolg mitgezählt
wird habe ich schon gesagt so hell
leiter herrschen werde guckt euch das an
das ist so kurz habe ich auch gemacht
und hab es einfach nicht verlinkt ohne
witz ist muss so oft passiert sein also
locker 80 oder 90 prozent aller fälle wo
ich sage das weil ich es verstecken
keine ahnung aber zurück zur story in
dem fall hat sie mir gezeigt die pappe
super alles gut dann ist sie natürlich
während der aufnahme ausgeteilt was
jetzt nicht so optimal für den verlauf
des videos aber das meer um das siegel
ging und nicht
irgendein feiert zusammen oder
gegeneinander hat das auch halbwegs
gepasst und hier ist beendet habt ihr
euch geschnitten hat hochgeladen perfekt
und dann dachte ich mir am selben abend
noch cool kommt jetzt aus der uni wieder
zurück ist noch eine runde sämtliche zum
runterkommen alles wie üblich auf den
server anmelden und sehe dass hier und
da dachte ich mir so eine woche gebannt
für chieming und das obwohl wir nicht
ein einziges mal zusammen irgendwie
gegangen sind - soweit ich mich erinnern
kann ist das nicht passiert und meine
wir wären einfach so unsere wege gehören
haben uns zwar nicht angegriffen das ist
richtig und ich will auch gar nicht so
tun als wäre der ball super
ungerechtfertigten wir mich beschweren
oder sony kann man auf jeden fall so
geben aber eine woche direkt ist schon
heavy muss man sagen ja so ich habe
natürlich gefreut
kommt ihr nach hause wollte einfach nur
ein bisschen spielen und dann heißt es
erstmal ins sind eine woche bahn und ja
es ist sogar noch härter getroffen leute
verliehen hat sogar einen zehn tage bahn
bekommen dafür zehn oder 14 tage also
die jetzt wirklich gut erwischt die arme
ich will mich auch gar nicht über den
banden beschweren wie gesagt ich hab's
mal gemeint den kann man auf jeden fall
zu geben es war nur dem moment bis zum
heavy für mich und du bist liegen das
bisschen länger ich dieses bisschen
länger weg und danach habe ich auch noch
mal so auf twitter getötet so dass kate
alles klar
das sind so die sache natürlich jetzt
passiert die erste davon zumindest die
zweite sache ist eine sache die ich
sagen möchte und zwar vielen vielen dank
an euch für die unterstützung in den
letzten tagen der kanal hat er echt ein
bisschen aufgedreht auf jeden fall danke
für die unterstützung und vor allen
dingen danke danke danke danke für die
unterstützung auf dem gestrigen video
deshalb nicht besonders gefreut also auf
dem wie man nicht trainieren sollte
video bei das für ein ja eigentlich
let's play kanal doch ein recht
ungewöhnliches video ist anliegen dem
irgendein typ sie quasi sport macht und
rumspringt und ja gut ich will nicht
sagen dass dann nicht komische
kommentare kam aber alles in allem war
die reaktionen doch sehr positiven
resonanz sehr gut gefallen und dafür
wollte einfach danke sagen und
appliziert drei tagen fest aber ist es
nur für euch und er glaubt nicht wie war
das
ungelogen gerade eine sauna mein zimmer
ich weiß nicht warum aber zimmer
irgendwie so eine einzige art die
begabung sich so krass gestört
aufzuheizen wenn ihr einfach aufnehmen
die ganzen tag über hält man vollkommen
aus so alles klar so vielleicht angenehm
was ist ein ort an dem angenehmes klima
herrscht keine ahnung sagen wir sagen er
habe so stellt euch vorbei also mir
angenehm alles gut also nicht zu ekelig
war und dann wenn ich meinen computer an
schmeiße meine softbox anmache okay die
trage natürlich auch dazu bei dass
bisschen wärmer wird aber dann wird es
einfach instant zur sahara mein zimmer
also ungelogen als ich jetzt nicht
läuten es sind jetzt knapp bemessenes
inhalt wirklich 120 grad lufttemperatur
hier drin
sobald ich einfach nur den anschalte auf
einem pc drücke und die softbox aufmache
und dann die nächste sache über die
verträgen möchte ist das hier als ich
möchte nicht in meinen kopf reden möchte
auch nicht über meine stirn reden oder
über mein gehirn oder sowas sondern über
meine haare die mich in letzter zeit ein
bisschen abhacken ehrlich gesagt ich
weiß nicht ob irgend jemand von euch
schon mal lange haare gehabt hat die ihn
abgefuckt haben aber es kann durchaus
sehr abhaken
ich frag ich wahrscheinlich so enden wie
können lange haare abhacken diesen doch
will ich ja leute so habe ich auch
gedacht ich dachte auch einfach so per
korbleger lässt sie einfach lange haare
wachsen ist den kopf wachsen da musst du
ihn nicht mehr style perfekt problem
gelöst einfach jede morgen den zopf
machen und erhält dann den ganzen tag
über und weckt nie wie das teilen alles
gut da ist es nicht so leute ich habe
auch so gedacht aber doch dein was
letzten endes passiert ist dass sobald
ich mich nur einen millimeter bewege als
wirklich ich werde mich jetzt hier gar
nicht von der stelle bewegen weil
instant meine frisur ruiniert wird soll
so bald ich zum beispiel gut
cabriofahrer ist natürlich krasses
beispiel aber zu weit wenn ich irgendwie
ich bewege ein meter laufen dann instant
links und rechts
so sieht das locker aus um die scheichs
links und rechts fallen die haare wie
gestört auseinander also schreibt mal
auf einer skala von 1 bis 10
wie das aussieht können meine kommentare
schreiben diese frisur hier gerade auf
einer skala von eins bis die gollner
also ich wusste wir es bewerten würde
aber das passiert wirklich jeden tag ich
lasse mir wirklich zu zocken also ist
schwierig aber es ist nicht der fall es
bei mir nicht
vielleicht bin ich aber zu dumm um zug
zu binden
ich möchte jetzt nicht ausschließen ich
sage euch wie es letzten endes aussieht
und letzten endes sieht so aus dass den
ganzen tag die dinge heraus fallen alle
15 minuten
die neuen zoff finden muss und trotzdem
nicht hält deswegen denke ich momentan
darüber nach einfach schnäbel die
schnitt alles ab mit alles macht nicht
alles als ich möchte nicht so ein army
schnitt haben sondern einfach die seiten
wieder ein bisschen kürzer schneiden
also die hier vielleicht kurz mal wieder
nach schneiden lassen
von oben richtig krass weg also wenn ich
den kids auf mache hier
ich will halt immer so davon so viel
abschneiden müssen bereit sein kaufen
wir konnten kein futter kaufen
aber leute wir sind wissen zum scheitern
verdammt aber auf jeden fall ich möchte
mir halt so zehn zentimeter auf meine
haare abschneiden weil die mir auf den
sack gehen die sind viel zu lange vor
allem im alltag ist schon schlimm genug
aber dazu kommt dann auch noch wie das
beim sport aussieht und ich sage euch
zum sport ist absoluter oberkellner geht
gar nichts mehr
alles klar könnte ich das machen ja ich
weiß das kind muss aber alles klar
ich habe also 20.000 jetzt verteilt
keinen hehl gemacht metlife wenn man
kurz und software machen dass unser weg
platz jetzt vize challenge hey what's my
name skaten business speed beide kills
das überlege ich mir in den letzten
tagen einfach so ich weiß nicht ich war
mal ganz kurz und soft zu haben war ganz
witzig war ein lustiger gag aber
irgendwann ist es mir einfach zu
unpraktisch also lange haare das
wirklich so unpraktisch gerade beim
fallen die so krass auseinander als ich
überlege mir möglich ob ich mir einfach
so ein armee schnitt holen soll also
drei millimeter rundherum einfach nur
weil es beim sport weniger nervt aber
nicht wird einfach mal interessieren was
ihr davon haltet so ihr als
steuerberater community ich weiß ihr
seid alle studierten architekten und
friseure und hat unter anderem auch kfz
auf lehramt studiert ja deswegen wollen
wir einfach mal fragen was ihr davon
haltet
weil ich echt damit mit dem gedanken
spiele
das problem ist halt dass es so ewig
dauert die dinger nachwachsen zu lassen
also ich hab mir die originale combo von
lala der saerbeck gleich du bist gleich
weg richtig ist am ende
es hat so land wieder auch die wachsen
zu lassen also ich hab die locker
eineinhalb jahre wachsen lassen leute
ohne scheiß und überlegt ernsthaft sich
die abmachen das einzige contra argument
ist eigentlich dass viele mädels auch
mir gesagt hat dass der topf besteht und
das ist halt eine halb fakten jahren
wieder wachsen zu lassen aber irgendwie
will ich diese ganzen haare los werden
dass für sie ballast den mann mit sich
herumträgt und stellt mir war so
befreiend vortrages abzuschneiden
okay das war heute einfach ein video wo
ich einfach scheiße gelabert hat über
dinge die mich interessieren
beschäftigen wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann lasst neider
bis zum nächsten mal heute ein und
schreibt uns in den kommentaren mit den
han